nicolas sarkozy rentre du proche orient
le départ du président français a été
marqué cet après midi par le suicide
d'un soldat israélien à moins de 100
mètres de l'avion à bord duquel ils
embarquaient avec son épouse sache
kovacs un dernier salut avant de rentrer
en france
c'était en fin d'après midi à l'aéroport
de tel aviv
carla sarkozy et le président embrasse
chaleureusement leurs hôtes israéliens
soudain c'est la panique dans la
délégation française
la première dame rendement à toute
vitesse les marches de l'avion le
président suit sans se presser un coup
de feu vient d'éclater à une centaine de
mètres les gardes du corps accompagne
ehud olmert et shimon pérès à leur
voiture
deux femmes soldates s'évanouissent on
craint un attentat mais c'est en fait un
policier israélien il vient de se
suicider pour des raisons inconnues
quelques minutes plus tard l'incident
est clos ehud olmert t shimon peres sont
remontés dans l'avion pour rassurer le
président sarkozy le chef de l'état
décolle enfin pour paris le proche
orient est décidément imprévisible